it'll be barrios making his third start
of the year against the white sox he's
had one good start
one not so good start a couple of two
out singles here
and here is edwin encarnacion
high fly center field buxton now to the
gap in right center giving way to kepler
and the singles are left aboard and we
have a scoreless turn
one down for cave three and two to cave
fastball got him as ostendial grounds it
to third moncada on the hunt at the line
with a howitzer for round number three
montana now at second base in scoring
position banner nomar mizaro
starts it towards the middle of the
plate lets it run off just a little bit
but still
over the plate magical comes in 362.
no homer seven runs batted in six of
those rbi have come with two strikes on
him
and madrigal goes the opposite way down
the right field line and this ball is
fair
nikki two strikes with a parachute down
the right field line and a one-nothing
lead
they were playing him deep all the way
around i mean this entire outfield was
playing nick
very deep and it cost him a run so the
bases will now be loaded
for jose abreu the pitch
swung on rolled back up the middle and
it's picked up at the second base bag by
adrianza he steps down the sack
and now sets up the potential double
play ball off the bat of nelson cruz you
want to cruise
ground ball to the left side fielder by
anderson throw to second for one the
relay is going to be in time
just as the doctor ordered six four
three double play to end the inning
[Applause]
[Music]
so we can match up two angles at the
same time matching time codes so this is
the same moment in time from two
separate angles watch the tag in one
bottom right
and the hand and the other one top left
and save the call so they will overturn
so ostidio will bat after two walks in
the inning from dylan
one to two he caught him down to his
knees
and the inning is over strikeout number
four for dylan cease
and saying there's a ground ball
tim's gonna take it himself and rack him
six and three
another double play for dylan cease from
a power hitter for the twins
and they're gonna go after polanco who
walked his last time up
to center and down for a hit a two out
delivery
by polanco ties the game at one
well the two run scoring hits so far in
this game have been
combined exit velocity of about a
hundred but
sometimes that's all it takes leads off
rio still out there
rio shakes off now nods his head here's
the pitch
a little jam shot that's going to be
caught by adrianza
fastball popped up short center buckston
in
still coming in and it's kepler making
the catch and it's a one two three
bottom of the fifth crews will come up
with the bases loaded
nelson cruz tears at him with cave the
lead runner
andre yanza behind donaldson at first
another one-two pitch here it comes
swing and a miss strike three he got him
strikeout for evan marshall and they
strand the bases loaded
here's a single his first time has been
retired the last two times
that's torn to left field and a time
won't get there
he's done that before against the sox
jose into second base
and he's got a two uh double two on two
out for edwin encarnacion
tap left side of the diamond picked up
by polanco throws to first
wade is there and the inning is over as
the white sox
strand two back to back two out walks
and here comes donaldson
they're loaded up and nelson cruz will
have yet another chance here
first pitch from alex grounded up the
middle
tim anderson to first on target
your heart can breathe normally
oh my and they're also going to talk
about adam angle who basically with two
on nobody out here in the eighth inning
is a candidate to put down the perfect
bunt they creep
in at the corners adam's ready to swing
and he does slash
all the way through and the socks take
the lead
adam angle with a ruse and it's 2-1
socks big base hit for angle
and a couple of walks set it up sox have
the lead
adam angle and now tim anderson bats
with runners at first and third and one
out it's 2-1
white sox in the eighth tim lines it up
well to left field
cave back of the wall it's odd defense
clanging away
here comes one more tim races for second
on an
rbi double
[Applause]
and then add a couple runs so here is
byron buxton
as the twins down to their final out
[Applause]
rip to left and out of the reach of
jimenez and the game still alive
now he's got he's up in the air buxton's
going
to third and he's going to come around
and try to score
and he will score for now
it's a home run now they are going to go
to new york and check
on this yeah they're gonna put him i
believe it's second base i think they
put him at second take the run off the
board
jake cave the batter there
it is sox win the opener with two in the
eighth
what a game well this is as exciting as
a game could possibly be with four runs
scored total